we always hear from filmmakers that they
have that IMDB Pro account and they find
that agent or manager for that big-name
actor that they want and they get the
big oh I'm so sorry
you know they're not taking you know
unsolicited scripts right now things
like that how would you advise another
filmmaker to get their project into the
hands of a big-name actor it sounds like
planting seeds early you know a lot of
these relationships that sound like they
started along - yeah you have to you
have to build the relationships early
not with actors a lot of directors think
oh I'm gonna have that you know Marty
Scorsese Robert De Niro you know
relationship and that one actor is going
to be my guy for 20 films or something
and they make friends with actors so
they go to parties and they make friends
with actors the problem is you can
develop a relationship with an actor be
friends with them for 20 years they
could become the next Tom Cruise and
then that week that you need them
they're in rehab you know so you're
screwed you have no backup plan what's
better is to develop relationships with
talent agents and talent managers and
because they will always have a stable
of clients they you know they won't just
have one client
they'll have oh if this person is busy
how about this person you're like yes
you know and they will you know and they
may change jobs they may be at the one
agency this month and a year later that
a different management company but they
kind of stay in that same circle of
talent so those are good relationships
you know to know and and you know I mean
a lot of times people filmmakers will
say well I'll just get myself an a-list
casting director you know and start with
that and they wind up paying all this
money for an a-list casting director and
you know are giving them a producer
credit or whatever it is but at the end
of the day that casting director is the
one they've got their own agenda you
know they're only going to be so
passionate about it and there's only so
much they can do and I think it's much
better to have you know a casting
director that's really passionate about
your project no matter how experienced
they are and it has the stamina to stick
with it for years you know because it
will be years and then to work with them
to develop these relationships
with with new you know with talent
agents and managers but the other thing
is to is to find the junior people or
the people at the smaller at the
mid-level agencies and to kind of start
to start you're building things up from
there or to find new york agents or new
york managers because those the ones in
New York the New York offices of the big
LA agencies they have more time they
tend to be better educated or at least
they think they're smarter but they're
not the LA people are busy pushing
pilots you know they're pushing every
all the actors to be on pilot season the
New York people their main function is
to get the L a fancy actors onto
Broadway from time to time or
occasionally indie films so they're
better attuned to knowing which of their
actors want to do substantial material
and can afford to do it and they have
more time to do it then the other trick
in talking to any of these agents or
managers is you know I mean I see this a
lot other filmmakers will come in they
and they have their lists
they got okay I've got to have this
person I got to have Leo and you know
Ben and Jamie you know whoever it is and
if I don't have them I wrote it for this
person I you know it's got to be this
person and then you find out you can't
get that person where that person's died
you know whatever but so the trick is
both creatively and also just
practically you don't have a list though
I mean which is to say make lists plural
of people like oh this person who might
be good this person might be good but
don't get it in your head that it's got
to be this one person or another because
yeah and and the practical side of that
is then you can go into the agents and
the managers and say look here's the
script here are the parts you tell me
who do you think would be good either
your own clients or someone else is
calling to you tell me who would be good
and all of a sudden these agents and
managers who normally they just get
offers and they process paper and they
either say yes or no usually no you know
someone's actually asking their opinions
like oh my god I went to Penn and and
you know and USC and the Peter Start
program and
someone's actually asking me something
creatively about making movies they get
really excited about that that's what
they live for and no one ever asks them
that so if you engage them in the
process they will do a lot more they
will go a lot farther for you they will
now be emotionally invested in the film
and and that's worth more than gold
so and whether that's a junior agent or
an assistant or senior agent you know it
once you get one person at an agency you
really latches on then they become your
best advocate and they'll tell everyone
else there and then you also need to get
used to playing them off against each
other so oh this agency well you know
you got a great client there but you
know we just made an offer to this guy
over at this agency oh oh really
oh well then okay we better read that
script then you know so you know they
play the Hollywood game and you gotta
get in there and you gotta play it
harder and and don't be afraid to you
know and and like I said a long time ago
at the beginning of the conversation it
it's Hollywood is very much who you know
but it's easy to get to know people so
if you go to a film festival and again
this is why you should go to film
festivals before you've made your film
you know get go to parties and hang out
with agents and managers you know they
may be horrible people but you need to
suck it up and buy them drinks and get
hit on and hit on them whatever it takes
you know because then when you are
casting a year later or two years later
or even a month later you know it's like
hey yeah we're Facebook friends oh okay
yeah yeah sure sure
you know yeah I follow you on twitter oh
yeah okay yeah sure see you've got to
create friends out of these people
whether you want it or not yeah yeah so
but yes it's those kind of relationships
and again it's it's not just the cast
that you can't just count on the casting
director to do it you've got it
you've got to get in there and stick
your feet in it because also what
happens is then I mean I've done this
with casting directors on both my last
films how
suck my casting director on this one
analyst turetsky on the last one who is
of course a producer on this one where
we developed this great kind of
shorthand where the casting director is
talking to a talent agent or manager and
says oh yeah now that's very interesting
huh let me run that by the director you
know and oh the director this and the
director oh can the director call you
later and they get very flattered know
what the director wants to call me you
know yes and then I come and I call you
know likewise if I have a relationship
with an agent or manager I'll say oh
yeah that's nice well I might casting
director follow up with you and they're
like oh he's got a casting director oh
it must be real you know it's a team you
know and then meanwhile like Alice and I
would both say oh and our assistant will
drop the script off invariably it would
be me yeah I know where to park in every
messenger parking lot in this town you
know so so again part of is just playing
the game and and and having fun doing it
to having these meetings with actors or
auditions if you're doing auditions you
know it helps and it helps you as a
director like CEO okay this person is
bringing this interesting has this
interesting perspective on the part you
might find out cast that person maybe
I'll use that I'll rewrite the script or
tweak the script or you know or do
something on set that was someone
completely different suggestion so it's
it's a good that's why I say it
some people get bogged down like oh it's
a process is the chore is like no it's
an opportunity it's fun to do casting
for a filmmaker that has a limited
budget and is only planning to pay
hundred dollars a day to a big-name
actor how realistic do you think it is
that that actor would do it for that
price well it's more realistic than you
think I mean if if the part is good yeah
remember I said if the part is good not
necessarily if the script is good
because actors pretty much only read
their own part which is fine and you
have to know that going in and so if
their part is a good meaty part or
something that they've never done before
you know that for whatever reason they
want to do that thing whether it's a
drama or a comedy here whatever it is
you can get them for example with open
house my previous film we write we're
looking
it's a great sign bus bench ad I'm Sally
Kellerman on there that's a prop from
from the last movie but I like her
license numbers on them yeah it's very
real course you gotta have a license
number otherwise what's the point so so
with open house originally my friend
Larry Maddox and I wrote the script it
was just a straightforward comedy and
then it was only when we decided to make
it as our own little low-budget movie we
tried selling it we couldn't sell it we
turned it into a musical and one of the
reasons was very specifically because if
you have a musical you can get better
actors because so many actors in LA or
in New York whatever love to sing and
never get a chance to sing because most
American actors started working started
in high school and every high school
does musicals so every actor got their
start in musical theater it's the fact
oh so now whether they can sing or not
is another matter but the point is that
they rarely get a chance to sing and
they all say they want to sing so if you
have a musical you can get better
actress so that's the other way to do it
is take your if you give you're having a
hard time casting just turn it into
musical Winter's Bone
the musical
you